into this
country just here
they bring more country money into the
country than anything else well I mean
the palace they don't they do a look
when Harry got married it cost so much
it was over a hundred thousand people
went to Winter
they had to pay accommodation they have
to transport they made a fortune they
take annual rents
because the 300 attacks 300 million per
year
when I go abroad and I say where are you
gonna go everybody wants to go to London
the palace will still be there I know
where the long clean Secrets there's no
King I mean my daughter just come over
from New Zealand okay
no
she's paid and all that money goes into
the government she's paid she's paying
you know Nutella here she won't be here
sorry
that's okay